[Music]
it's a ever-evolving frame a journey
like that was my inspiration my father
did a lot of Monty Python films and
Terry Gilliam stuff as well and I used
to come and every holiday muck around
the workshop especially faces changed in
my father's days it was more physical
unless the effects nowadays we are a
medium which the effects like to use to
to supply them with decent elements but
it's also slightly destructive
especially actors Department brings to a
production the chaos and mayhem if you
get given a task they tell you the image
they want to see what's our job to work
out how we get there if you want to put
an environment where you've got access
in a room and the room is supposed to
explode we achieve that in-camera safely
and effectively
you know how it's going to look in your
head but you also love back that goes
crazy you know this way in that way it's
a technically challenging thing to do
and to make it look good at the same
time we handle gas we handle water we
handle wind we handle smoke we handle
high tailings we handle engineering
blood it's not you know everything
everything you can possibly imagine is
our choice it's massive I was consider
special place as an art form it
certainly is so much I can not do about
it for many reasons I love absolutely
love it
hey everybody even more
behind-the-scenes footage from the
season seven battle so let's break it
down just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far the tagline from this is set
everything on fire
they said they set way more stuff on
fire during season seven for obvious
reasons obviously they have all the
dragon battles but there's all the stuff
going on at sea so if you're new to the
channel there's going to be a whole
bunch of Game of Thrones footage
dropping soon be sure to subscribe to
get it
I do giveaways every week this new
footage focuses on a couple key action
set-pieces
notably Greyjoy battles between Euron's
forces Theon and Yara then the scenes
that are happening up in the north with
Jon Snow and tormance group that go
beyond the wall and then Daenerys just
lighting everybody on fire on Dragon's
Back the early stuff here I love what
he's talking about Monty Python because
that's Holy Grail so it's obviously the
same type of genre albeit a lot of
comedy there's a lot of Monty Python
Easter eggs inside Game of Thrones just
because the writers the producers are
huge fans it was that scene early in
season four during the first siege of
murine where the old masters sent the
night out and he was cursing at them in
high Valyrian just cursing at Daenerys
before Daario took him down what is he
doing he says that for an army of men
without man part
he claims you in a woman is fooled but a
man who hides his [ __ ] in his own
[ __ ] he was actually quoting Monty
Python that had been translated into
high Valyrian by the person that does
all the languages for Game of Thrones so
even though Game of Thrones isn't really
a comedy series they baked a lot of
comedy into it so it's just a way for
this special effects person to say that
they do a lot of practical effects like
blowing stuff up and a lot of CG effects
too with green-screen
with like Daenerys writing on drogon a
lot of this might look familiar from the
season 7 trailer we haven't seen
Daenerys on dragon back in the trailer
yet but that'll probably show up in the
next trailer they drop and she could
always be on dragons back in this scene
here but he's so small and frames that
you wouldn't be able to see her
this is his shoulder blades that she's
sitting behind so he gives you an idea
of how big his torso is not quite as big
as balerion the black dread but it looks
like it corresponds to this scene here
where she just burning something alive
in this field here and it's sort of the
way they cut this trailers they'll show
you something outside like where it is
that they're filming the scene then the
CG part of it that they insert with that
so like you see them out in this field
here then you see Daenerys riding on
dragon back then on the soundstage you
see the flame jet through in the camera
get pulled through so it's almost like
when we're in these big battles with
drogon just tearing into all the
Lannister forces will be on the ground
in a much bigger way than you saw during
season 6 so in episode 9 when Daenerys
was setting all the old masters ships on
fire you actually got some of their
perspective as they were looking up at
all the dragons burning them imagine a
much more hardcore version of that I
don't know if we'll get to that in the
first episode because it seems like most
of that's going to be dedicated to
getting Daenerys to Dragonstone and sort
of getting settled there while everybody
else is deciding what to do
- might be the first time we see any
really big battles they cut a little bit
of season six footage into this daenerys
during Episode four when she was setting
all the cows on fire like they should
they basically set this Hut on fire on a
soundstage then they shoot Daenerys
pushing this over somewhere else and
then inserted so it's not like she's
standing around a bunch of fire while
they're doing this but as cool as the
dragons are from a cinematographers
perspective I'm actually most excited
about all these great joy scenes because
this big ships that they actually built
a bunch of this and they're going to
blow it up so they shoot the flare then
they insert the flare with the practical
CG set then they start dropping a whole
bunch of fire bombs on the deck and then
separately they create all these sparks
in the air and insert it with Theon so
you get all these sparks in the
background lighting them up it just
looks really beautiful when it all comes
together but that's another good
question is where are these Greyjoy
battles going to take place because it
seems more likely that Euron would come
around to fight the nurses forces if
they're already heading for Dragonstone
but Cersei clearly says that she has
enemies to the west of them and she's
talking about euron greyjoy even though
everybody's going to be finding each
other in the beginning I think the
likelihood of a year on Cersei Alliance
is very high because Daenerys is going
to help dionan Yara take the Iron
Islands back from their uncle so it's
sort of like the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
so naturally you can assume that euron
greyjoy is probably going to harass
Lannisport a little bit but once de niro
starts laying into Circe's army they're
going to need a lot of help dealing with
the nurses unsullied and their weakest
when they're at sea because that's where
your on is most powerful so first big
question where do you think that most of
the euron greyjoy battles are going to
be do you think we'll see them in the
western sea or do you think that by the
time episode one rolls around he'll have
already come back around to the eastern
sea most of these scenes beyond the wall
where they're laying down extra snow for
special action set-pieces seem like
they're later in the season because John
seems like he go to Dragonstone first
then they'll decide what to do then
they'll end the season somewhere up
north of the wall where they're doing
all this stuff in the trailer here
during a normal season they would break
up they're really big hardhome level
episodes they might get like two of
those that season now it sounds like
they're going to try and do that more
than a couple times just because they're
only
seven episodes they're spending the same
amount of money so what you'll see is
way more action way more character
interactions and even though there's
total less runtime like the total
minutes of Game of Thrones you get
during season seven is less than during
season six because all the characters
are in Westeros you see a lot of them in
scenes together more than you would
before so fewer episodes where you don't
see certain big characters they used to
do that in the past like you just jump
around like last season I don't think we
saw Arya till episode 2 now it's going
to be pretty much everybody in every
single episode
they've been posting these behind the
scenes about once per week so I'm
expecting that to continue we'll
probably get our next really big trailer
next week maybe the week after that but
sometimes they post on weird days so
whatever ends up dropping I will totally
do a video for it leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below there's going to be so
much Game of Thrones coming in the next
month so make sure you click the bell to
turn alerts on so you don't miss any of
it but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner lucas s please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round the next
time I post Game of Thrones
while you wait for everything click here
for more of those behind the scenes
trailers and you can click here for all
my other season 7 videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight